George clooney is like the gold standard
or for class and dignity and he gets it.
He once said,
my famous is my currency,
and he uses that for causes that are
important to him.
I think Brad and Angelina are pretty
remarkable in the way they've managed
their family,
their public image.
To me,
Madonna is just amazing in her ability
to remain relevant for a very long time.
You know,
I look at celebrities having been in
Hollywood more than 20 years and
following it,
a lot of people are famous for their
moment,
but people who are still relevant 20
years later,
to me that's.
That's pretty darn impressive.
I think a lot of these corporate ceos
live in a different world.
They live in a world of multimillion
dollar bonuses.
They live in a world of private jets and
that's the mill you they live in and I
think the auto companies got it.
They,
they had a misstep.
They got it.
They drove back to Washington the second
time and look what happened.
They got a deal out of it.
So I think there's a lot of.
They require people and people liked me.
Just because somebody is a CEO of a
company,
I need to tell them the truth.
I need to say,
you're not playing this right or this
isn't going to work right now for these
reasons and whether they choose to
listen or not.
I look at it as a responsibility of mine
to deal in reality because if I don't
tell them and they go out,
they're going to say,
why didn't you tell me?
If I do tell them and they still choose
to do it,
maybe they listen next time.
There are people who don't care about
the rules.
I use the.
I used the example of former vice
president,
Dick Cheney.
He.
He knows people don't really like him
out there.
His poll numbers are down,
but he figures,
screw you.
I'm the.
I was the vice president of United
States.
I had all the power I wanted and I'm
beyond caring about what my public
images and he somebody who transcended
that.
We look at somebody like Ann Coulter,
the political pundant,
and she likes to be intentionally
provocative.
She likes to say words that will upset
and shocked people.
The n word and the f word and get the
press and then doesn't care because she
believes that all press is good press,
which is not something I necessarily
believe.
In fact,
that's one of my core beliefs that no,
not all press is good press,
but most people who are in the public
eye,
they have earned it.
Maybe Yoko Ono's tired of it after all
these years,
but again,
unless she does something pretty
significant or makes an appearance in
what you're not going to see about her,
some people have to do a little
something to keep their interest going
in there.
Man.